is russia committing atrocities in
ukraine images of bodies in civilian
clothes in butcher have led to
international condemnation their calls
for a war crimes investigation against
moscow but can the accusations be proven
in court this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
fuli batibo ukraine's president has said
negotiations are the only way to end the
conflict with russia but after the
discovery of bodies in civilian clothes
in the town of bucha near kiev some with
their hands bound to their backs
vladimir zelensky says talks with moscow
will not be easy he wants president
vladimir putin tried for war crimes
accusing him of slaughtering civilians
russia has strongly denied the
allegations saying ukraine's special
forces staged the killings in response
several eu nations including germany and
france are expelling russian diplomats
and the eu has announced a new round of
sanctions against moscow imran khan has
this report from butcher a warning some
images may be distressing
surrounded by heavy security and the
media president vladimir zelensky
visited the town of butcher near kiev
after witnessing the devastation he made
a promise that justice would be done
it's war crimes that will be recognized
as genocide by the world you're here and
you see what has happened we know about
thousands killed and tortured people
with cut limbs women who have been raped
and children have been murdered
we know there's so much more this is
genocide
on march 10 people here began to bury
the dead in a 45-foot trench dug in the
grounds of a church some 68 bodies at
first some victims of war others who
died of natural causes
the priest of saint andrews church says
he had to negotiate with the russians
who occupied butcher to allow the
burials but as the war dragged on more
burials
in total 130 were buried here
and the mass grave was needed all across
butcher the dead lay in the streets for
days even weeks even now they wait to be
picked up by overworked undertakers
at the burial site people had wrapped
some of the bodies in black plastic a
little dignity in death
their families took some solace in the
fact that they were buried next to the
church many had come to be wed or attend
sunday service before the war
the priest leans on his faith to deal
with what he's witnessed
there is a lot of hatred and injustice
that people feel but christians should
forgive but to forgive doesn't mean to
forget we can't judge only god can judge
some bodies have been moved from the
mass grave to morgues in and around the
town since butcher was retaken by
ukrainian forces
i'm here looking for my brother we were
close we talked every day
but until now i don't know where his
body is
i'm going to try the morgue someone sent
me a picture and told me i need to come
to identify him i hope he is there this
is likely to be one of the largest
burial sites in the town but is by no
means the only one in fact across this
city people were burying their dead
wherever they could in their backyards
in common areas anywhere where they
might be able to give their dead some
dignity and some respect
for ukraine's attorney general in kiev
gathering evidence of potential war
crimes is now the priority
we started in our investigations
actually from
24th of february this year and now we
have more than 4 000
just cases about war crimes and near
2000 cases which are connected to war
crimes
now these days all words speak about
butcher european storm
and in butcher justice for war crimes is
a concern for the future the dead have
seen the end of war but those left
behind are desperate medicines and food
are in limited supply and what is
available is quickly grabbed by those
who have little of their old lives left
imran khan al jazeera
well russia's foreign minister has said
that the bodies that were filmed in
bucha were put there after the russians
left sergey lavrov warned the
accusations could threaten
[Music]
another fake act was arranged in the
city of bucharest in kiev region after
the russian military left from there in
accordance with the plans and agreements
reached there was a staging there a few
days later which is widely promoted now
through all channels and social networks
by ukrainian representatives and their
western patrons
but u.s president joe biden says there
is strong evidence of atrocities he says
were committed by russian troops he's
called for president putin to face trial
he is a war criminal but we have to
gather the information we have to
continue to provide ukraine with the
weapons they need to continue the fight
and we have to gather all the detail so
this could be an actual have a war crime
trial this guy is brutal and what's
happening in bucca is outrageous and
everyone's seen it
well let's now bring in our guests
in berlin hugh williamson the director
for europe and central asia division of
human rights watch in moscow andre
antikov a political analyst and in
newark new jersey
alexander hinton director of the center
for the study of genocide and human
rights and distinguished professor of
anthropology at rutgers university a
warm welcome to you all thank you very
much for being on inside story before we
begin our discussion let's take a look
at what is considered a war crime
according to the u.n it's a breach of
international law committed against
civilians or enemy combatants during an
armed conflict the geneva convention
defines a war crime as a willful killing
torture or inhumane treatment not
justified by military necessity and
carried out unlawfully and in an
unprovoked manner and the international
criminal court has since expanded the
list by including crimes such as forced
pregnancy which is intended to affect
the ethnic makeup of a population let me
start with you alexander hinton in new
york new jersey do the images that we've
seen come out of butcher this week meet
the definition of a war crime yeah i
think and first of all thanks for having
me on uh but absolutely it's one piece
of a larger puzzle uh that clearly makes
the case that war crimes have taken
place i think you need to look at this
in the larger context of the violence
that's been perpetrated by russia and
ukraine uh the aerial bombardment or
obliteration bombing that's taken place
uh and as expected as uh you know people
go back into the towns that were held i
expect that we're going to have many
pooches
but certainly
in this larger context it fulfills the
definition meets the definition of war
crimes and alexander the ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has even
accused russia of genocide what
constitutes genocide genocide if we
think of war crimes as
attacks on combatants and non-combatants
during the course of an armed conflict
genocide involves
the intent to destroy
and whole or impart
uh national ethnic racial uh or
religious group uh and whole are in part
uh as such because of who they are and
their different acts not just killing
but everything from killing to the
deportation
populations uh
anyway so do you believe that's
happening in ukraine right now
i think we need to gather more evidence
but what we do know is happening because
there's a systematicity to genocide that
needs to be proven to meet the legal
definition uh so as i said as we go in
and gather more evidence
we can begin to get that sort of legal
determination but ultimately it doesn't
matter because it's one of a cluster of
atrocity crimes that include war crimes
crimes against humanity ethnic cleansing
and genocide
are known together as atrocity crimes
and
the international community has agreed
that all states their national community
has an obligation a responsibility to
protect
populations against human atrocities are
being perpetrated and this is clearly
the case in ukraine okay andrei antikov
in moscow let me bring you in now
shocking images out of bush and no doubt
moscow has denied that its soldiers had
anything to do with these atrocities and
says the images are fabricated we heard
from sergey lavrov we heard from the uh
the russian ambassador at the u.n as
well what do you think do you think
these killings could have been carried
out by the russian military
no i don't think so the problem is that
uh the russian troops have withdrew from
bush on the 31st of march and the same
dame uh the same day uh the head of
bucha has recorded a video where he said
that really russian troops has uh have
withdrawn and he didn't mention anything
about uh those bodies he said everything
is okay in the city but when the
ukrainian army has entered the city a
couple a couple of days after the
russian withdrawal uh eventually we've
seen those images and those videos so
the question is uh why why didn't
anybody mention
these videos those
bodies
before the ukrainian army has entered
the city this is the the real question
second there is no secret that uh the
bodies of the dead people start to decay
uh very fastly i mean it's not about
days or weeks it's about hours so
uh if those bodies uh lay a light uh for
weeks or days uh so
they they would have some signs of decay
and the smell of course but it seems to
be that those bodies were brought
there uh by the ukrainian army to make
a so-called show
another point is that
we hear the word genocide
way why i talk about genocide uh it's
because
uh to my mind the ukrainian army the
ukrainian government is trying now to
retake
the
the the russian stories i mean
russia has accused the ukrainian
government of genocide uh committing
genocide in the in zanbas region but now
we hear the same accusations uh against
russia so okay it seems it's uh
yeah yeah okay i hear what you're saying
let me bring in hugh williamson now to
respond to what you've just heard you
from andre
about the date of russia says it's
withdrew from bush on the 31st of march
they say that the bodies were maybe
probably brought there by the ukrainian
forces i know that human rights watch
has been to butcher you've started
investigating what have you seen what
have you found
human rights watch published a report at
the weekend
which
looked at apparent war crimes by russian
forces in the first half of march
in butcher and elsewhere
in butcher we identified a case um based
on many interviews and other evidence
where russian soldiers executed uh
a ukrainian man at a short distance in
the back of the head by shooting him
while he was kneeling on the pavement in
the street in butcher
this was during the the acknowledged
russian occupation of puja we also
published a statement um about evidence
in the first half of march
of a woman whose husband was shot we
don't know the circumstances of that
shooting but the russian troops denied
her access to her husband's body for
many days
so
um my colleagues have been in butcher
for
the last couple of days today and
tomorrow we're beginning an
investigation about the aspect of the
bodies we don't know
the circumstances in which those three
or 400 bodies were killed but we are
extremely concerned that
these could amount to war crimes because
uh we have identified at least one
example of a war crime by russian
soldiers in butcher
and we're entirely unconvinced by the
russian explanation that uh somehow the
bodies were placed there we find it
entirely unconvincing right uh and this
uh hue is not the first incident which
has led to accusations of war crimes uh
being leveled at russia right there was
the uh incident of the mario pole
theater of the theater in maripo exactly
i mean human rights watchers documented
other examples of apparent war crimes
the targeting of civilians the targeting
of buildings where civilians are are
staying for instance the theater for
instance schools and hospitals
the um
blocking of humanitarian aid to cities
under siege like mariopol
the use of banned weapons in ukraine
such as
um
anti-personnel landmines and cluster
munitions
um
as well as other examples of summary
executions we also documented a case of
um of rape by a a russian soldier in
eastern ukraine in early march as well
by the way we should also say we've also
documented um issues around the mis the
uh
the way ukraine has handled russian
prisons of war and we've published two
statements on
concerns about that issue as well okay
concerns and i will ask you about the
accusations of genocide that russia has
leveled at ukraine for what's happening
what they say is happening in the
donbass region in a bit but i want to
bring back andre
into the conversation and respond to
what you've just heard from human rights
watch andre russia's saying that the
bodies in butcher just coming back to
what what is happening now that that
evidence is fabricated but how is russia
going to be able to prove this how is uh
human rights rights watch or anybody
else going to prove that
russia is responsible for that i
doubt that we can rely on human rights
watch investigations you see the problem
is that now we hear the accusations
against russia but we also see that
human rights force and other
organizations just close their eyes on
the uh on any crimes uh committed by the
ukrainian forces for example lately
we've seen the exchange of prisoners
between russia and ukraine we got our
prisoners with their fingers cut off and
their genitals cut off does the human
right forge
human rights watch take it in mind i
don't think so
moreover i would like to remind you that
a couple of weeks before the ukrainian
army has
bombed the city of donetsk
with the cluster bomb so where was human
rights rights watch at that moment i
don't know so we can't rely on human
rights which maybe we need an
independent investigation uh
and who would lead that independent
human uh investigation i mean human
rights watch is considered an
independent organization when it comes
to investigating such crimes just a few
moments uh previously i mentioned why we
can't
uh rely on human rights watch and we
can't consider it okay well if you
williamson please respond
absolutely absolutely i mean if there's
evidence of um
um misuse uh abuse of prisoners of war
we will certainly examine that as i said
andre we've published two statements
which raised concern about
apparent
war crimes against russian prisoners of
war by ukraine human rights watches
mission in ukraine is to uphold the laws
of war that means the the
behavior of all parties to the conflict
russia and ukraine so it's not
particularly credible to suggest that we
are biased in this given also we've
issued several critical statements about
ukraine
alexander hinton let me bring you uh
back into the conversation now we've
seen increasingly blurred lines in
ukraine between civilians and fighters
ordinary ukrainians have taken up arms
and gathered for example to make molotov
cocktails so under international law are
they still considered civilians when
they've been taking up arms and could
this give russia legal cover
i know because if you're looking at war
crimes right it covers both combatants
and non-combatants so either way that
doesn't really matter
i'd like to sort of weigh in on our
earlier discussion um with andre as
claims i just want to point out that a
classic form of denial
is too divert a way to focus on the
small and to not look at the big picture
to not look at precedence not look at
history
russia has a long history of committing
atrocity crimes we can go to
grazny aleppo a number of different
places
the false statement
that russia made that genocide was
taking place in dambass has been
debunked i've written about it i've
helped debunk it um atrocity crimes were
committed on both sides right there was
different sort of mass human rights
violations to place them donbass that's
chronicled there have been monitors
who've observed that it chronicled it
but there's nothing remotely resembling
genocide that took place there that's a
false claim and again
uh different forms of denial including
genocide denial uh perceive and
precisely this way casting doubt on
things in terms of bucha the washington
post looked at aerial photographs
satellite images
of bucha and there were dead bodies on
the ground in the same places
so you know we look forward to the work
of human rights watch we should
certainly listen to
different motions different complaints
that are brought forth by russia
but again if we look historically
we can see that russia has a history of
making false claim
for example they said they weren't going
to invade
ukraine we can start with that right
andre your response i mean many experts
argue that the invasion itself is a war
crime it's a crime under the conception
of aggressive warfare
if we look historically so we should say
that the ukrainian so-called ukrainian
army that
has cooperated with the uh german with
nazi germany and has committed so many
war crimes that
it's even hard to imagine they killed
the
little children
they
they killed the women they killed the
people
all over that region so
i don't think it's uh
it's uh
we can
just close our eyes
on what the so-called ukrainian army has
made during the world war two uh as for
the butcher to return to bucha i have
already mentioned
some questions so why uh the governor of
bucharest the head of butcher didn't
mention
any bodies on the 31st of march when he
recorded his video he didn't mention
that but uh what
were the the the ukrainian army
has mentioned those bodies when it
enters the city of bucha a couple of
days after after the russian withdrawal
this is the uh the question
also i would like to remember yeah that
still need to be answered and as uh hugh
said the investigation is ongoing who
let me ask you now what happens after
the investigation what evidence is
required i mean the icc has already uh
started an investigation into this into
the war in ukraine but what happens i
mean what evidence is required to pro to
prosecute perpetrators and and how solid
does it need to be
um so it needs to be very solid so first
of all we uh we would point out that for
a war crime it is actually the
responsibility of the state that commit
whose soldiers commit that crime as a
responsibility to hold those soldiers to
account so it's actually russia's
responsibility the human rights watch is
is calling on russia to to investigate
these allegations of war crimes by its
soldiers and to hold those to account
and prosecute them if necessary
um if that doesn't happen then we
welcome the fact that the ukraine has
launched an investigation in butcher and
elsewhere and send some experts to the
area we encourage them to do the
to do the investigation thoroughly
and carefully bodies need to be
preserved evidence needs to be preserved
testimony from witnesses needs to be
gathered
we also welcome the fact that the
european union and the united states in
the last two days have committed to
sending specialist investigators
including forensic experts to butcher
and elsewhere because that can help
with with gathering information and that
all of that information by official
bodies can contribute to the to the
international criminal court or other
bodies defining whether these were war
crimes or not and if they were then a
court case could could start in the
hague in the international criminal
court against russian military officials
or others but alexander
neither ukraine nor russia is party to
the international criminal court
to the rome statue so neither can really
bring allegations to prosecutors and the
international court of justice which
rules on disputes between states uh you
know both have roles upholding the rules
of war which of these two bodies you
think is more apt to take on a case like
this yeah well there's already a case
for the
icj but more broadly there are a number
of different options in terms of
accountability you can have commissions
of inquiry that can be undertaken you
have the work that's done by human
rights monitors
as we've been hearing about
you can also have domestic courts that
are established also through the
principle of universal jurisdiction
which has proliferated recently you can
have other countries um you know bring
bring suit uh hold people accountable so
there are a number of different uh
options that can be brought forth
who who would be prosecuted in this case
would would it go as far
up as president putin himself
well we know we know that it would be
very hard to uh arrest and put him on
trial but people can be tried uh you
know suits can be brought forth without
the person being
present
if they don't show up of course they
lose a degree of credibility
but certainly i expect and i'm virtually
certain that we will see a number of
accountability processes that move
forward
but we also need to think about
transitional justice uh and also the
reconstruction of ukraine and in the
longer term finding a uh way to find
peace in the region right which is
absolutely critical andre i'll give you
the last word would russia cooperate
with an international investigation
yes russia is ready for that but
this investigation must be really
independent at the moment i see that
there is no independence in this
investigation when we talk about
american experts or any other experts
they are not independent it's
obvious to my mind and
i have already mentioned some questions
that have to be answered before
we hear accusations against russia or
against ukraine so
if we answer those questions at least
a couple of them so we will see
the truth but it seems to me that nobody
is interested in truth we we hear the
accusations and
we hear that uh president putin is
responsible for that and that's all i
think it's a media case it's a political
case it's not about the human rights
it's not about genocide it's not about
war crimes it's about politics nothing
more thank you for your time thank you
very much gentlemen for an interesting
discussion i wish we had a bit more time
alexander hinton andrei antikov and hugh
williamson thank you all
and thank you for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
fuli bativo and the whole team here in
doha thanks for watching bye for now
[Music]